字幕: Yuri Ueda
校正: Natsuhiko Mizutani
最近 私はカメラにハマっています
自粛期間中 家の中で
ひたすら写真を撮り続けたり
近所を散歩して写真を撮ったり
ある時には 雷が落ちる瞬間の
動画を撮影したり
また 休日は美術館に行ったり
両親の知り合いの芸術家に
会いに行ったりしています
しかし 私は幼い頃
現代アートが大嫌いでした
これが小さい頃の私です
アートに囲まれて楽しそうに
見えますよね
両親は芸術家で
私は３歳の頃からバイオリンを習い
アートと音楽に囲まれた生活を送っていました
週末になるとギャラリーや美術館巡り
しかし そこでは意味不明な
現代アートの作品がほとんど
子どもには理解しがたい
キツイものもありました
それは 父がボランティアで
写真撮影を行っていた
現代パフォーマンスイベントです
これって 子どもには
かなり刺激が強いんです
例えば 裸の男の人や女の人が
ダンスとも言いがたい―
なんとも奇妙な動きをする
パフォーマンスとかを見ていました
イベント中に鼻血を出したこともあります
そういったアート三昧の生活の中で
私は おかしな大人になるんじゃないか
これって子どもが見ていいものなの
学校の友達は 休日に
現代アートなんか見ないんだろうな
平凡になりたい もっと普通がいい
と思うようになります
気味の悪い現代アートから逃げるように
小学校で必死に勉強します
化粧品の研究者を夢見たり
英語に興味を持って
海外に留学したりしていました
今思うと 勉強することで
嫌いな現代アートから自分を切り離し
正しい大人になれる と
思っていたのかもしれません
この頃から 国連やNGOなど
国際貢献に携わる仕事に
憧れを抱くようになります
そして 高校２年生の時 教科書で
「エル・システマ」という
プログラムに出会います
音楽教育を無償で
貧しい子どもたちに提供し
犯罪や非行に巻き込まれるのを防ぐ
という画期的なものです
すごい と感動した私は
とにかくこのプログラムを知りたいと
ロサンゼルスに飛びました
そして「エル・システマ」で
チェロを学んだ兄弟に出会います
私たちは出会った後
一緒に音楽をやろうということになり
毎日放課後にセッションをしました
私は英語が下手でしたが
音楽を一緒に演奏することによって
仲を深めることができました
音楽芸術は国境言語を超える を
肌で実感したんです
そして帰国後 憧れの国連や
NGO職員を目指して
東京の大学を目指します
しかし 大学受験に失敗
私は大きな挫折を味わいました
何とか専門学校に入学を決めた後も
まだ夢を捨てきれず
NGOでインターンを始めました
しかし 実際にインターンをすると
私が描いていた理想の職業とは違う
現実的な部分が見えてきました
それぞれが持つ文化背景が異なる中で
お互いがぶつかり合ってしまい
思いどおりに進んでいかない
ジレンマを感じました
職業としてのNGOの難しさを知り
私がやりたいことは
これではないかもしれない
と思うようになります
だからと言って やりたいことが
何なのか わかりません
そんな時 父から
現代アートに関する情報誌を
作らないか と誘われます
その時 私はこう思いました―
これは もしかして
やりたいことを見つけるチャンス
とにかくやりたいことを見つけなきゃ
私は焦っていたんです
苦手だった現代アートでもいいから
目の前に来たものは何でも
チャレンジしようと思いました
そして 父 母 私の３人で
「さくらペーパー」を作り始めます
私は「さくらのアート散歩」という
コーナーを担当し
現代アートの個展についての
コラムを掲載し始めました
このコラムでは 現代アートに対して
素人目線から見た
率直で素直な感想を書いています
この頃から 私は急に現代アートと
関わることが多くなりました
小さい頃のアート三昧に戻った感じ
しかし 私はこの時
現代アートを面白い と
自然に受け入れられたんです
作家が作品に込めたメッセージや
遊び心を感じ取ることができました
その年の冬 普段はシャッター街の暗い通りに
珍しく光が灯っているのに気が付きました
芸術大学の教授と学生が
たたまれた喫茶店や理髪店
焼肉屋などを利用して
五条川の桜の木を利用した
作品を展示していました
五条川とは 私の家の目の前の
桜並木が有名な川のことです
展示されている桜の木は その年の
激しい台風によって倒れたものでした
咲くはずだった桜を ガラス細工で作って
その木に咲かせてあげる
私はこの作品の美しさとメッセージ性に感動し
その時家にいた父を わざわざ
会場に呼び出すほどでした
こんなにも美しいアートプロジェクトが
家の近所で行われていることに
とても誇りに思えたんです
しかし その教授が今年退職の予定で
来年行われるかは未定だといいます
このプロジェクトが一回きりであれば
このような印象深いアートとの出会いも
すぐに忘れられてしまう
どうしたらこのようなアートプロジェクトを
継続させることができるんだろう
私はこの疑問をきっかけに
大学でアートプロジェクトについて
学びたい と思うようになります
この時 私は現代アートをすでに
嫌いなものとは思わず
親しい友人だと思っていたんです
親近感がわいたんです
現代アートに触れると「ただいま」って
言いたくなるような
そんな感じだったんです
そして ２年間必死に勉強し
大学に編入することができました
ですが 今度はコロナです
大学に入学したものの 自粛生活を強いられ
やりたいことが遠のいていきます
リモート授業の毎日で 一日中
パソコンに向き合い 悶々としていました
行きたかった芸術祭も
劇場関係のインターンも中止
大学で芸術好きな友達を見つけて
一緒に美術館を巡るはずだったのに
やっとここからがスタートだと思っていたのに
そんな私が見つけたのが
冒頭にお話ししたカメラです
コロナ禍で目標を見失い
何事にもやる気が起きなかった私にとって
面白い写真や動画を撮ることが
唯一の息抜きになっていました
外出する時は 必ずカメラを持っていきます
歩いてアイスクリームを買いに
行く時でさえ 持って行くくらい
カメラが好きなことに気がつきました
父の影響で現代アートが大嫌いだったのに
結局 私も同じように
カメラを使って表現をすることで
自分が救われたことに驚いています
そして 春からは就職して
映像関係の道に進みます
これから失敗や挫折をすることが
あるかもしれないけれど
今 自分が選んだ道に行けることに
胸がワクワクしています
過去の経験が連鎖して
本当にやりたいことが見つかり
遠回りも悪くなかったな と思っています
これから先 大きな挫折があったとしても
新しい自分との出会いのきっかけに
なるかもしれない
一貫した人生じゃなくても
それはそれでいいんだ
苦手だった場所に また行きたくなるかも
変わることは恥じゃない
私はそう思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）